[Music]
your host and every week we're here
subscribe right now if you haven't
already and very hot topic you know all
over the news 24 hours sad to say
that you have extreme elements in every
different religion islam continues to be
the fastest growing religion
and it's a shame that the media is
giving all of the attention to a fringe
element
a extreme group of people so we're
bringing on
someone who was on the ground in syria
someone who's a journalist who's worked
for the news outlets
documentary filmmaker and he's actually
had encounter with some of these people
he's here to tell us
his story from being on the ground his
experiences
who in talking and relating with some of
these people over these issues
and making it clear making it clear
because anyone can quote
scripture out of context to show where
these people went wrong
the clear text from the quran what is
permissible and what is not
and scholarly sources he has written an
article about this that he's going to be
going over with us
because someone can go ahead and say
look jesus
as he said i haven't i've been sent not
to promote peace but
i came with the sword and bring my
enemies here those who wish did not
reign over them bring him here so he can
kill him
now somebody who's a christian look and
say hey hey you're cornered out of
context exactly
people take things and interpret them
according to their desires then you can
you can go ahead and write havoc in the
land so we're going to clear this up for
once and for
all because we know what islam is about
islam says
love all mankind and islam is a way of
life of mercy compassion
love and we got some love for you so
continue to watch
watching the dean's show when we come
back we're going to be discussing this
very important topic
don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
this is the theme
[Music]
back here on the dean show with brother
billau
how are you sheik how's it going
alhamdulillah i'm good
how are you doing alhamdulillah most
people out there in the world
we know that you've done many
documentaries you've done some wonderful
work trying to clear the many
misconceptions
about islam but for the people that
don't know you tell us a little bit
about yourself i know you accepted islam
uh way back in the 90s is that right uh
yes
uh i accepted islam about about 18
years ago and um i was muslim for maybe
about a year
and after accepting islam i had so many
people coming to me with so many
different things
about what i should and should not be
doing what's right and what's wrong
that i decided that i wanted to learn
the religion
so actually i left america and after a
brief stay
in khartoum in sudan i went to egypt
when i went there i went there to study
the quran and to learn the arabic
language
um after that uh
well some years later well shortly after
that i got married and egypt kind of
became my
my first home after america of course
um sometime after that uh i had always
had a background in media
and i was the first program director for
huda tv
um after some years at huda tv um i
think people
your audience is familiar with uh with
that channel uh ultimately i wanted to
do some other things i wanted to report
and do some wider reporting on the umma
but huda tv really wasn't conducive to
that they
were more holding fast to a schedule
of just religious programming and i
wanted to do more social and political
uh programming so then i started to do
uh independent documentaries
and journalism and recently
i spent about a year and a half almost
two years
not straight time but there and back
there and back but most of the time
over the past two years i was in syria
and i was also in libya and
did a documentary from there as well so
uh this is pretty much what i've been
doing here recently
what was it about islam we know
according to the guinness book of world
records
that islam is the fastest growing way of
life in the world now what was it about
islam with you in particular everyone
has their own unique story we're not
going to just go into that deeply in
this show we want to talk about some
other important things
but in brief what was it about islam
that fascinated you to accept it
tahit and it's as simple as that
you know um it's i have a funny story
you know when i was about
oh about five or six years old my mother
bought a very heavy glass bowl that had
fruit in it
so she told me as i was sitting in the
kitchen i'm gonna put my bowl
in the refrigerator now i don't want you
to touch it she said to me
i said fine no problem she puts the bowl
in the refrigerator with the heavy fruit
in it
and she walks away and i couldn't wait
to touch that bowl
yeah no sooner did she walk away that
me being a young boy i couldn't hold the
fruit
the the bowl with one hand it fell it
broke on the floor
into all these little pieces and i heard
my mother's footsteps coming
back into the kitchen and i knew i was
dead so it's at that
moment that instant that you call on
your lord
now i had been um raised as a christian
so normally people would think that you
would call on jesus
but me myself and that flash i said
i know jesus was a human being but i
know
that my lord doesn't sleep he's not
busy and his attention is not diverted
and he'll listen to my prayer
so right away i said oh god and then my
mother came into the kitchen
and uh yeah we'll just cut the story off
there
so so it was the pure monotheism tohi
translate
you could say it was the pure monotheism
direct dial-up connection with the one
who created you
well it was natural for me it was normal
for me it i didn't
it was really really a turning point
even though i was such a young boy
it's that i just knew naturally that
i had a lord and he was the all-seeing
the all-knowing
so when i got older and then i actually
heard about the concept of tawheed that
i wouldn't have to be afraid of anyone
except my lord
i wouldn't have to pray to anyone except
my lord i wouldn't have to do anything
for anybody anytime anywhere
except for my lord and i like that
that's beautiful
tell us uh you we talked about you know
the documentaries that you do you're out
there trying to
really portray the correct image of
islam the beauty of islam
and now why do you feel what enticed you
to write you're also
as a journalist as a documentary maker
you also
write many articles and one of them in
particular that we're going to be
discussing today
we want to give people have leave them
with something to ruminate about
uh you actually did this article because
there's a lot of negative propaganda
now on islam and you you discussed this
these two opposing viewpoints in your
article what enticed you to write this
article
well the article that uh you are
referring to
appeared on my website it's called uh
isis ideology
regarding killing non-combatants the
case for it
and the case against it um
i got to know many uh isis fighters
during my two years of filming while um
uh
while in the syrian territories i did
reports for channel 4
uh sky news news and holland and um
and uh other media outlets
and while i was moving around i got to
know a lot of
people from the free syrian army to all
the way to isis and everybody in between
and i realized that uh
there's a lot of misconception regarding
this group uh
called isis or isil or is
or what have you the issue is this
the umma is hurting and they have been
hurting for a long time
so therefore they're really quick to be
able to
latch on to any movement that they
feel is going to basically um
right some of the wrongs that have been
committed and i think that this is where
a lot of people in the umma are going
wrong it's kind of like this thing
of the enemy of my enemy is my friend so
therefore
they are uh they become very attached to
this group
and i don't think that that is the um
correct uh uh idea because the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
made mention that never will my ummah
unite on that which is misguidance
so therefore there's no way that we
would have
all of the scholars all of the scholars
in unison
that condemned isis but
yet there would be people who would
still think that isis
is a good idea that what they're doing
is a good thing
so as long as we have these
misconceptions i believe it's upon
people like me
who spent time there and know them
firsthand
we ate at the same restaurants um uh
uh depending on what group that i was
with at that time
and all i filmed some of them on the
same battlefields
and um even visited them in the
hospitals
and i talked to a lot of them and i
tried to encourage
some of them not to go to isis but they
opted to do that
anyway so the reason for this article is
i felt that it was uh
important for me to try to clear up some
of the misconceptions
that people might have so i wrote the
case for
the killing of non-combatants from their
own
propaganda this is not from my own
uh self but from their uh own propaganda
and then i wrote the case against it so
that's pretty much where this article
came from
i'm going to take a break and we're
going to come back with more on this
really
hot topic with brother bilal
who was actually like you said filming
documentaries you were reporting as a
journalist
in that area so you first hand
experience and you're going to
be answer be with us some more so we can
answer some have us uh
uh cover some more questions that i'm
sure on the minds of many of the people
we'll be right back to continue this
interview here on the dean's show
jihad often mistranslated as holy war
the word jihad means to struggle islam
does not preach violence
it does not preach vicious holy war it
certainly does not condone terror and
suicide bombing
islam preaches compassion tolerance and
justice
find the truth about islam call toll
free
877 why islam please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean show with brother
bilal
journalist documentary maker clearing
the many misconceptions on
about islam and muslims now uh this is
very uh
for a lot of us i mean this this um you
know when we come into islam
we we learn about the mercy the
compassion
the love you know uh and all of these
beautiful things but now
when we see and we know there's a lot of
negative propaganda against islam
so now what can cause someone to go
ahead because
we know that it's clear killing not
combatants you know the prophet peace be
upon last and final message sent to
mankind who's the brother jesus moses
they all came with the same message
where's the
worship the creator not the creation and
you know to to be
of the best of character
to be the best of examples for mankind
you know in morality
in in compassion now you see people
uh who are using islam
and quoting some kind of evidences that
you'll discuss with us
killing journalists aid workers is there
any kind of room here
for someone as a muslim to commit some
kind of crimes like this
well i think it's important that
everybody understands where this
ideology is coming from
so therefore they could you know
they could know exactly we're supposed
to be at but i want to start this by
saying
um there are some ideas and
misconceptions i think that are out
there that this isis group
is a group that was formed in in uh
he you know the creation of the enemies
of islam and i tell you i don't believe
that
i believe that many of them are sincere
but misguided i believe that they're
sincere
but misguided for example they
use as a proof to kill non-combatants
for example it says
verse number 126 and if you punish
punish with an equivalent of that which
you were harmed
but if you are patient it is better for
those who are patient
uh so allah subhanahu wa tala is making
mention here that if you are punished
with something or you are harmed with
something then you return
fire with that which you were uh harmed
with
so they use this as a proof to say
that they kill our innocence so
therefore
we kill their innocence they may say the
united states government
uh has uh has killed innocent muslims
okay
and this is this is true this is correct
however
is the correct understanding of this
verse
that we can now say okay well they've
killed our innocents so now we can kill
their innocence
and they use this verse as a proof for
that
now before we talk about the other side
of it i want to bring another verse
instead of
verse number 36 wherein allah says and
fight against
the disbelievers collectively as they
fight against you collectively
and know that allah is with the
righteous now once again they understand
from this verse that it's permissible to
attack
all in a certain country without
discriminating
because they attack all in muslim
countries without discriminating
now let's look and see if this is the
actual proper understanding
of these verses and there are others but
for the sake of time
um let's stick with those two so you're
give you're giving us now
the the proofs that they will use to go
ahead and justify their actions
these are the proofs that they will use
to justify
their actions um there's one more verse
i want to quote from surah baqarah which
is verse number 194
wherein they say so whosoever has
assaulted you then assault him in the
same way
that he has assaulted you and fear allah
and know that allah
is with those who fear him now let's
talk about the case against it
the first thing that we have to
understand is that in surat
164 allah says and
none shall carry the burdens of another
so the first thing we have to look at as
this verse
if we've got some lady coming out of a
grocery store or a man
pumping gas in his automobile has no say
in american uh
foreign policy has no say in in
what the obama administration is
actually doing
then what would be his sin where he
where it's
warranted to take this man or this lady
and her child's life
because allah says and none shall carry
the burdens of another
now let's look at the verse which says
then assault him
in the same way that he has assaulted
you
now let's look at the way that the
scholar and i believe your
uh uh audience is familiar with
ebentania a lawyer
who and he gave an explanation for this
verse wherein he said
so if someone were to assault a person
and would call somebody a dog for
example
based upon this verse it would be
permissible to
say that that person him he is a dog
however you cannot say
that if somebody says well your father
is a dog
then you could say back because your
father is a dog as well
why because
father did not assault you that person
did not harm you that person's father so
therefore if it's an unfortunate
incident wherein
us a western plains were to kill the
children of
a person's family it would not be
permissible to go and kill the children
of of some westerners family because
no person should bear the burdens of
another
and we have with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says in a hadith which
is collected by imam
ahmed in his uh um
and it's in the sunnah wherein he said
the worst
people in the sight of allah is the one
who
kills someone other than the person who
committed the murder i will say it again
the worst people in the sight of allah
is the one
who kills someone other than the person
who committed the murder
now this means and it's very very clear
that we cannot take
oppressors as our teachers our teachers
the messenger of allah muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
so we cannot take somebody else as our
teacher
simply because they oppress us so now we
are going to do
what they did to us and in another verse
allah makes mention
and do not kill the soul which allah has
forbidden except by right this is a key
word here
except by right and whoever is killed
unjustly we have given his heir
authority
but let him not exceed the limits
in taking life indeed he has been
supported now why did allah
make mention about taking a soul
which has a right to be taken and then
he
said the exact same verse
but let him not exceed the limits that
would mean
that even though you have retribution
against the person or person
that uh that assaulted you or committed
a crime against you or committed a
murder against you
let him not exceed the limits that would
mean that
you cannot now go and say well i'm going
to take the life of this person's wife
because
if if for example if one person's wife
was raped
would it be permissible for for for us
to go and to rape someone's wife
of course not why because it is
inherently haram
when you have things for example burning
if
someone were to burn a muslim to death
would it be permissible for us to burn
that person to death no because
burning is only for allah
to do so it would it is the retribution
is inherently haram listen to what uh
even kathia said in his steps here
wherein he said
with about these his words but
let him not exceed the limits that allah
says
he even kadia said it was said that this
means
the guardians meaning of a murdered
person should not
exceed the limits by mutilating or by
taking
revenge on other than the perpetrator
of the murder and this can be found in
the tafsir
of uh of ibn kefir now uh evangelion
said
in his tafsir about this particular
verse
he said it means that we should not kill
other than the killer because the people
in the time of jahiliyyah used to act
like this
if one of them got killed the heirs used
to
kill someone more noble than the uh
in the clan of the killer they used to
leave the actual perpetrator of the
crime
alive but would kill others around there
so as
to uh uh to teach that person a lesson
so these are some of the boundaries that
need to be observed we're gonna take a
break so is it clear now in islam
that you have no justification even if
that wrong is done to you now for you to
go and kill betsy at the pizza parlor
or any innocent person that is a
non-combatant it's pretty
crystal clear in islam is that right i
don't think that there's any doubt about
it
the issue is that people have to study
if they don't study
then any time dick harry mustafa
muhammad
can come with any verse of the quran he
knows a little bit of fancy arabic
and he's got a beard and you wouldn't
know the difference it's kind of like
having a body with no immune system
we're going to take a break and right
back with more here on the dean
comic terrorism misconception muslims
are
terrorists this is by far the biggest
misconception of islam
given unfairly by stereotyping in the
public image that the media gives
has anyone else noticed how when a
specific group of people attack another
group of people it is labeled as a hate
crime
but when a muslim opens fire on anybody
it is quickly regarded as terrorism
many political dictators and officials
or extremist groups
use the name of islam as a strategy to
garner followers and attention
when many of their practices go against
the true basis of islam
the media has also portrayed islam as a
cult or club where if you join you
become a terrorist and that is now part
of your agenda
however all over the world people
practice islam in the true form
and use it as a way of life there are
many verses in the quran that go against
the idea of terrorism
some of these verses include fight the
way of allah those that fight you but do
not transgress limits for god does not
love transgressors
this basically means do not fight except
in self-defense
and even in doing so do not go beyond
defense another verse states
if they seek peace then you seek peace
which means do not attack people for no
reason or kill innocent people
there is nowhere in islam whether it be
in the quran or the teachings of
muhammad that promotes the killing of
innocent people
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below please also
help support the d
show by making a donation in the link
below
[Music]
back here on the dean show and we're
talking about this very very important
topic
um because there's a lot of uh
misinformation out there and confusion
and hopefully we're gonna be clearing it
up
uh by the end of this show we've seen
that there are many many
uh journalists who went out there and
they were reporting the truth
on the side of the muslims who are being
oppressed by the uh
bashar assad and now these people were
actually executed you also had a
alan hearing who was also uh
executed i mean what what do you have to
say about this
well uh alan henning
was an aid worker for maybe some people
who don't know his situation
he was an aid worker he was a taxi
driver who helped to raise some funds
for suffering
uh syrians and he came across he came
over with an aid convoy from the uk
it was a several day trip and they drove
it was an aid convoy with about 50 other
muslims he was the only non-muslim
and they crossed the syrian turkish
border last december
and they arrived in a town called dana
uh
this is a a town
where isis and other groups were
operating from
um there were other groups that were
waiting to receive this aid convoy
uh for suffering syrians it was a very
cold time people were wearing slippers
with no socks
in the freezing mud it had snowed so it
was really a bad time for suffering
series
uh uh alan henning had been at one of
the headquarters for approximately one
one and a half hours and then
the um isis soldiers came and arrested
him along with other muslims
they took them down to the headquarters
and uh basically they released all of
the muslims and they kept alan henning
behind
uh they kept allen hitting to make a
long story short
because they said that they wanted to
ransom him for something of course the
other muslims that were there protested
they said that he came with us to help
suffering syrians
how could you take him uh uh
uh uh to uh uh you know as a prisoner
when he came to help people they said
well first of all we've got some doubts
about him
and so on and so forth they said that
he'd been in a country for an hour and a
half what could he
what crimes could he possibly have
committed and then ultimately they said
look we're just going to keep him as a
prisoner and that's what they
uh turned out to do um they said because
the the
um and the us with their bombs and such
like that
killed many muslims which is true but
the reality of the situation
is that um is that this is the wrong
path to take because we are not allowed
to punish people who have not committed
crimes against us
as allah says he says and do not kill
the soul which allah has forbidden
except by legal right
so um made mention
about if someone were to invent lies
about somebody
for example you you know this is the
dean show
and i were to say hey you know this guy
who hosts the dean show um
you know he smacks some woman on the
corner of fifth and broadway
okay now would it be permissible for you
to make up a lie against me because i
lied on you
no why because lying is inherently haram
so it wouldn't be permissible for us to
do things like this so it needs to be
made crystal clear to the people
that islam will only be successful if
we follow the quran in the sunnah not to
follow our own desires
people have got to realize and
understand there are many people
fighting in the syrian territories
that are sincere mujahideen sincere
who are fighting um according to the
court and
to relieve the oppression from the
syrian people every foreigner that's
over there every fighter that's over
there is not fighting in the ranks of
isis
it might not look like that because cnn
fox news abc are giving
isis 24 hour a day coverage but that's
not the reality
so uh people i think should realize that
there are very sincere people who are
doing things in a good way
um and i think that they need to keep
those uh sincere mujahideen fighters in
their prayers
a couple more points before we come to
an end you mentioned the 24
7 coverage why do you think that is now
when when you have such a french element
you know you
have obviously it's clear in islam what
islam is and what it isn't
instead of bringing on qualified
scholars you know people who are on the
ground such as yourself for instance
you know to speak the truth on behalf of
islam and muslims
it's just like for instance giving the
kkk you know the microphone to preach
christianity the
west bro church you know when we had the
boko haram kidnapped those
girls you know on the on the flip side
you had for instance the lra christian
army
who who kidnapped 66 000 girls and no
one
you know barely heard about that so why
are they giving these french elements
the microphone
the media attention and and and this is
the exposure the average layman has
about islam why is this do you think
this is deliberate
well because i work in the industry i
think i can give you guys a window in
terms of how
uh of how this thing works first of all
i know the isis group they want to show
how ruthless they can be they thrive on
that
they do this is what they want to show
the people
so that the so that uh what they
perceive to be their enemies which is
basically everybody um so that their
enemies will be afraid of them
but then you look at the news media side
of it the news media
side of it loves to show action they
love to to scare mongering because
channels are businesses are corporations
and when each channel has a scoop or
the harshest uh uh interviews with the
people with the harshest language
all of that plays into them getting more
sponsorship
and having more people to watch their
news program
and then we look at security services
security services
are some of the most ignorant people
about what muslims in islam are actually
doing
you would think that a lot of these
people they do have lots of textual
information about islam
but some of the realities in terms of
why people do what they do and why they
are not doing what they're doing
they're either a grossly ignorant
negligent
or they choose to look away because it
is not popular in a democratic society
that they would establish a dialogue
with people whom they would deem to be
terrorists
so it's created like a perfect storm
and that's why you're seeing 24 hour a
day coverage
and um and i wish that there would be
more responsible uh
reporting uh we gotta we got a couple
more minutes left didn't the last and
final messenger the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
didn't he prophesize didn't he talk
about an extreme element
coming from amongst the muslims that
they would come
uh and didn't he warn us about this
yes and those people were known as uh
as the cowardice um
uh you know i i have to make so clear to
the people
so clear to the people that if you were
to study
basic things about islam basic things
it would unravel what a lot of uh
the misconceptions that out there that
are perpetrated even by muslims
and muslims would be more balanced so i
think that that
that's my primary advice to people is to
do more study and take
10 or 15 minutes a day to read reality
to read the quran and then you'll get uh
um you'll have that immune system
from some of the viruses that are out
there last question for the person look
they've been tuning on to the dean show
maybe they watched some of your
documentaries and i want you to tell us
where we can
where people can go to watch some of
your work before we conclude and they
they're seeing they love what you loved
you know that tohi the pure monotheism
direct connection with the creator
you know they love this compassion and
mercy and and all the beautiful other
teachings of islam
but now you have you know fox news cnn
they tuning in to sean hannity and
whoever else is out there the 24-hour
coverage with uh
the extreme elements now they're
confused what advice do you have for
them
um well you could uh you could visit my
website bilal
abdul karim.com you can follow me on
twitter
that's bilal kareem um or on facebook
under this under bilal abdul kareem
um additionally um there is a very
exciting project that will be coming out
in a couple of months
that is something that the muslim world
has not seen as of yet
that we are going to be uh helping
people to understand
exactly who's doing what and where and
how
and maybe even um uh you know make it
clear to the people
um who is pushing
aside agenda uh i can't give away too
many details right now because even
rasulullah didn't let his companions
know
where they would go home sometimes
for a particular battle and sometimes
secrecy uh actually
is your ally so uh i just asked the
people to please make dua
that we will have a successful project
that will benefit the muslims
and um i think that's what i would like
to ask the people to do
let's close with this tell us does islam
clearly condone or condemn the killing
of innocent men women and children
had an exalted standard of character
and we strive as muslims to have an
exalted standard of character
like he had we may not achieve that but
we certainly strive towards that
and i think anyone with a half ounce of
intelligence
islamic intelligence basic intelligence
and just a heart inside of his chest
would know
that killing innocent people doesn't
help the islamic project
it doesn't help to establish a a
khilafah
it doesn't help people to see the
correct image of
islam the correct image of islam instead
of a distorted image of islam and
let us not follow our desires and insha
allah will be successful
thank you so much for finding the time
to be with us may the creator of the
heavens and earth reward you
for all your wonderful work thank you
thank you brother for making that point
again crystal clear we know that islam
condemns it doesn't condone the killing
of innocent men
women and children especially now you
have innocent
humanitarian workers and now you're
going to go and kill them this is insane
and islam doesn't invite us to insanity
it invites us to clarity knowing why
we've been created the purpose of life
and
you know islam there's nothing in islam
that goes against humanity as a whole
that has leaves this despicable taste in
your mouth
no there's some things you might not
understand but when it's made clear to
you
you'll see that islam definitely with
all of his injunctions and makes sense
and when we study the life of the last
and final messenger we don't see him
beheading people you know killing
innocent people we don't see that he had
you know the best pr public relations
with people
and he did what was in the best interest
of this dean
and we see that in one example this is
one out of many
there was a tribe leader and his name
was
thumama ebenuthal when this man who was
a staunch enemy of the of islam
a staunch enemy that wanted to
assassinate he was an enemy to the state
and i'll leave you with this to ponder
and to ruminate over this it's very
fascinating story
this man was captured prisoner of war
now he was fed well
taken care of well you know not
disrespected he was put
in the masjid for three days he was
there
he was observing the behavior of the
muslims the call of islam
and at the end he was given a
proposition to accept
he rejected the prophet let him go look
look muhammad peace be upon him he let
him go
why did this man come back think about
this he was set free
but he came back and what did he do when
he came back he testified
he entered by giving the call accepting
the call of islam and making the
proclamation that there's nothing worthy
of worship he said i agree
what's in my very nature look that
there's nothing worthy worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth
and a simple everyday this is allah in
arabic allah
and that you muhammad salam you are
indeed the messenger of allah
look at that from this kind act of mercy
look this man came back
he wasn't beheaded and he came back he
was given the da'wah and he accepted
islam
isn't that fabulous so you know it's
incumbent on every muslim to get out
there and educate
to get out there and share the purpose
of life with the people and when you're
out there in society you're not an
isolationist
when you're out there contributing to
making the homeland
the community that you live in a better
place a lot most of the time you're not
gonna
end up wanting to have innocent blood on
your hands when you're out there
connecting with the people with the
struggle and strife
of the average everyday mo shmo joe
but when you're locked up maybe in a
room
and you don't get out you don't
communicate you don't give the dawah
you're not educating yourself properly
and then you listen to some
hate-mongering preacher and then
your mind gets warped so don't do that
no muslim wants to have innocent blood
on his hands no muslim because this is
one of the
evilest things that you can end up
having on your
account on the day of judgment but how
can you go wrong
calling people to the purpose of life
sharing this message of peace
when we greet assalamu alaikum peace be
with you
and that's what we're calling to peace
peace with your creator peace
within yourself and peace with humanity
and society
you cannot go wrong doing that never
but killing innocent people you will
definitely go wrong and you go astray
so we made it clear on this show
subscribe to the d
show follow us like us
on the facebook twitter and we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below